a lot of my students that have got a lot
of properties begin to get bogged down
with the paperwork the admin the
processes and it becomes almost like you
become this really successful property
investor then you end up with almost a
job an admin person managing all this
junk
my advice don't get virtual assistants
because they'll just have a part-time
attitude my advice is to replace
yourself by hiring somebody hire an
employee the employee that you hire you
want to write a training manual for them
all the jobs that you're doing that you
think someone else could do write them
down exactly how they're done put it
into a training manual when you hire
somebody hire an assistant get them to
do all these jobs every time they have a
question for you you need to help them
when they get stuck help them add it
into the training manual this ever
growing ever evolving training manual
when that employee leaves which they
probably will you can easily replace
them because you've got a
training manual which is doing basically
all your junk that's my advice when you
stop succeeding in property